[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the only person who's
not in spider-man no way home at this
point and throughout this video we're
going to be going over some brand new
details we found in all the recent tv
spots and trailers first up though i
want to talk about a big theory that i
have after watching the tv spots now
from the second trailer we know that
doctor octopus ends up in a prison below
the sanctorum but no one as of now knows
how he gets there in the second trailer
we watched as he wrapped peter up in his
tentacles and also had him upside down
against a pillar if you slowed down the
footage you could make out that peter
was running very low on nanotech and
there wasn't enough to cover his full
body this is very similar to the fight
between tony and thanos in infinity war
in which stark's supply kept depleting
and it left him with almost no armor
there's a point in which the dock goes
to smash his tentacle against peter's
chest and peter only survives this
because the suit moves up to protect his
body ark is clearly kicking the crap out
of him like he's four months late on the
rent and it doesn't seem like there's
any way that peter can get out of this
that is unless doctor octopus frees him
i actually think that hawk will end the
fight by giving up and that once his
evil ai is shut down that he'll
willingly go with peter now i have a
couple of theories over why this is with
the first being that it's the nanotech
taking over his tentacles which is what
saves him in the trailer we did get a
shot in which we could see the nano
machines moving over his tentacles and
doc ock seemed dark shocked by this now
if you cast you might hurt but now if
you cast your mind back to spider-man 2
you may remember that it was actually
the ai in the tentacles that turned otto
octavius into a bad guy and thus if the
tentacles can be shut down then this
might be what saves peter his tech is
from the early 2000s whereas the stuff
in the iron spider is from a time when
the wakandans had opened their doors to
the world and thus their futuristic
machines have helped those in the mcu to
leap ahead of where we are now therefore
it kind of makes sense to me that they'd
be able to override the ai and the
tentacles and that could calm the dock
down and make him see that it's all just
one big misunderstanding now it might
also be because as we've seen from the
tv spots dock realizes that this isn't
his pide in this moment he could
discover that he's on another earth and
this might make him call off the attack
when we see him in the cell he seems
like he's almost willing to work with
peter and at one point in the trailer
he's blown out of an apartment block by
an electro blast i actually think that
doc awk might end up becoming a good guy
in the film and after the ai in his
tentacles as needed he'll help peter
stopping the rest of the bad guys in the
second tv spot we could catch doc ock
talking to his tentacles saying looks
like we've got competition ark of course
spoke to them quite a lot in spider-man
2 and thus i think it's hinting at these
ai being the things that are driving him
this competition line is actually also a
reference to the iron spider bringing
out all of its arms and i can't wait to
see these two sides go head to head a
really cool little detail is that when
peter's iron spider nanotech goes to
cover his chest you can see that his tie
is pulled up as it moves to block the
tentacle ketu is seen below the
sanctorum when we see peter talking to
strange and you can see that the bottom
of his tie has been cut off meaning that
this bit probably happens immediately
after the bridge this might mean that
strange intervenes to help peter but let
me know your thoughts below and how you
think doc gets captured other moments
from this scene include doc ock bringing
out a sharp blade at the end of one of
his tentacles and this is similar the
scene in spider-man 2 in which he
captured ant-may now the third tv spot
showed their standoff in more detail and
it had both och and peter fighting all
over the bridge during this clip we also
got cuts of happy phoning peter to ask
who the new villains are although this
is kurt to make it look like it's
happening alongside the bridge scene we
can see that this scene happens at night
and i actually think that it'll be happy
leaving a voicemail this is kind of a
flip on the situation in homecoming as
we saw peter constantly leaving
voicemails for happy and happy wasn't
too happy
[Music]
in the trailer we know that there's an
explosion he's on the outside of in his
car and as it's at night i kind of think
those two scenes will happen pretty
close together happy also says that one
of the guys is made of mud and this is
clearly referring to the sandman now
though he's not mud per se i do get the
feeling that peter might use water on
him at some point and this will make him
appear to be like dirt in spider-man 3
peter did the same thing when fighting
him in the subway and happy dropping
this line could be hinting towards that
other shots in this spot include the
lizard growling and jay jonah jameson
asks if it's a dinosaur you might also
notice that lizard's hand just has four
digits on it instead of five and this is
because in the amazing spider-man
captain stacy blew it off and it then
regenerated with less fingers so that he
was more in line with the reptile this
scene also happens outside the apartment
block so my guess would be that the
villains swarm this area and then fight
at it in the first trailer we did see a
moment from this scene in which sam and
electro fight in the air at one point
there's also a pumpkin bomb thrown which
peter dives at and this is also the
location where electro blasts stockhock
in the air at i actually think that mei
will die during this scene and it'll
sort of call back to when green goblin
bomb mae's apartment during the first
spider-man movie in the trailer we can
catch you running in the lobby right
where the explosion goes off at and
happy looking in makes it seem like
someone has just died the trailer also
opens with tom holland in the rain
looking completely devastated so my
guess is that there's a big fight here
which may is caught in the middle of now
if you're enjoying the video so far we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this each and every day yeah my
eyes and ears out here so if you noticed
any other easter eggs then make sure you
drop them in the comments below as i'll
massively appreciate it now the fourth
tv spot has a shot in it in which we can
see sandman reaching out with his hand
and it looks very similar to the moment
from spider-man 3 in which he first
gained his powers i'm not sure exactly
what's going on here but we can see a
wall behind him and this could be the
sanctum sanctorum strange says over the
top of the clip that the villains all
die fighting spider-man in their own
universes and from what i've heard on
the movie we'll learn that toby maguire
ran into sandman a couple of years later
and put some dirt in his eyes both he
and the lizard survived the films that
they were in but strange saying this
makes me think that the rumors are true
he tells peter he's sorry and then peter
grabs the magical cube and according to
leaks on the film this is actually
what's used to house the villains in
place and send them back to their own
realities as they all died there because
of spider-man the peter of the mcu feels
a lot of guilt and thus he'd rather they
live than be sent home to die peter is
very much just interested in protecting
life and this is somewhat the opposite
to doctor strange who will happily send
the villains to their death to protect
his reality strange has always been a
dark horse in the mcu and there was even
that line in infinity war when he said
that he would happily sacrifice peter
and tony this is why he's so adamant
about stopping him and the tv spots also
contain more footage from the train ride
in the mirror universe we see that the
rock formations and city have become one
and that the dimension is starting to
fold in on itself honestly i think this
cgi looks a bit it does look unfinished
and i really hope that they add more to
it as it just looks very unpolished it
looks like when eddie brock did those
forged spider-man photos in spider-man 3
hey got got references on this channel
now we can see that peter is gripping
the cube at this point but there's a
weird moment in which he says there has
to be another way strange says there
isn't and you can see his face from the
side against the void in the mirror
dimension however later on in the tv
spot when strange is saying that he
couldn't stop them it looks like the
same shot but flipped with a background
filler added so i'm thinking that sony
is lying to us about this scene
according to daniel rpk toby and andrew
will come into the movie at the hour and
a half mark and they'll have a lot of
screen time so we're being misled and
thinking that their arrival comes at the
statue of liberty i really hope that's
true and it would explain why these two
shots are the same and why that shot of
strange and the statue of liberty at the
end of the trailer looks so bad i think
this is just benedict against a green
screen and they've made this moment for
the trailer as it looks unfinished and
doesn't really fit in with the rest of
the new teasers
hello
what's that epic hero shop are giving a
massive 15 off in their black friday
sale this includes all of their nerdy
clothes and merch thank you for letting
me know andrew garfield and toby maguire
yes that's right epic heroshop.com are
doing a big sale and they've opened up
their entire vault of t-shirts and are
even re-releasing a lot of them
including the new rock star's latest
obsession ones i've bought a number of
them including this amazing king shark
jaws one got a loki one my man a venom
versus carnage one and even a zemo one
where he's puppeting punks like you into
spending lots of money oh paul you look
so swagtastic will you marry my daughter
shut up punk i'm married but if you buy
those clothes i will make an exception
for you thank you paul that is very
generous i will i've left a link in the
description below so head over there
right now and get some amazing merch
with 15 off come on yeah you don't want
to live a life full of regret where your
biggest mistake was missing out on this
sale so head over there or i'll ratio
you i'll ratio your family and i'll
ratio everyone you know
thanks for thanks for sitting through
the head take care of yourself
now tv spot 5 is very electrocentric and
i'm glad he's finally getting some
attention after spider-man forgot his
name and also his birthday i'll never
forgive you spider-man however we also
get some shots of mj saying that peter
should warn her and ned before he
attempts to change the universe again to
me this confirms that the spell didn't
actually work and instead all that it
did was break the multiverse open though
peter stipulated that people who already
know should carry on remembering the
reveal i don't think that strange
actually finished the spell and thus
everyone still knows that he's
spider-man i think the movie will end
with them sending the villains back and
then strange will carry out the spell
once more which will finally make people
forget you might also notice that mj has
the black dahlia necklace on that peter
got her in far from home but it's
missing some pieces because at the end
of the movie it got really busted up we
also get a much better look at electro
who definitely has a stark reactor
powering him due to the triangle on it
it looks a lot like the one that tony
created during iron man 2 and this brand
new element could be allowing him to tap
into all kinds of new resources in the
amazing spider-man 2 his electricity was
blue but here it's golden and perhaps
the arc reactor has helped him to
harness a new kind of energy i
absolutely love the design especially
how they've made the electricity go over
his face so it looks just like his mask
from the comics and i think it works
really well with the rest of the mcu
designs in this tv spot we also see
sandman wrapping his hand around peter
and sandman having a giant fist is
iconography that pulls directly from the
comics i don't know if it's just me but
the sun looks a lot darker than it was
in spider-man 3 so this might be a side
effect of him getting older if the leaks
about spider-man catching up to him
years later are true then perhaps he
started to rot a bit and this could be
why happy said he thought that he was
made of mud i don't know if sand agents
either but yeah just theories theories
coming out or left right and center here
now a brand new tv spot which was
released yesterday shows far more of mj
and peter swinging through the city in
this peter asks if they should head to
mj's house to hide out and she says that
her dad will kill her peter says i
thought your dad really liked me and he
says not anymore which is hilarious as
he's now of course being accused of
murder yay now it was long theorized
that nick fury was actually mj's dad but
this scene pretty much finally debunks
that as peter has already met fury and
would know that they were the same
person the next spot showed doctor
octopus in the sanctuary in prison with
strange asking him if you recognize the
tom holland version as his peter parker
he said no and i think this comes in the
conversation in which strange explains
to peter about the villains popping up
and how the multiverse is real peter
first heard about the multiverse in far
from home from mysterio but it was
thought to be fugazi much like the rest
of the master of illusion's tricks
however i think this will be strange
showing peter that there exists other
versions of him out there in alternate
realities this scene also clearly
happens right after the bridge one when
arc is being captured as we can see
peter is wearing the suit and severed
tie that he had on in that fight
throughout these scenes dark ox tentacle
heads are closed and if you cast your
mind back to spider-man 2 you may
remember that when they were open and
had a red light on that they were in
control juxtaposing this when ark was
the one who was leading the charge they
had a white light on the bridge when ox
says it looks like we've got some
competition we see that they're red ones
some more but their heads being closed
in the cell makes me think that ark has
regained power over them in other news
we also had the daily bugle tick tock
account set up which will be bringing
you lots of updates from jay jonah
jameson and his staff betty brant is now
working for them too and she dropped
this video yesterday which is a bit
funny hi tik tok i'm betty brandt some
of you may know me from my award-worthy
work for the midtown high student paper
but i'm super excited to announce i am
the newest intern for the daily bugle
and i'm going to be running our official
tick tock account this is an honor and a
dream come true i promise to bring you
the fair balanced and hard-hitting news
you've grown to expect from the daily
bugle i can't believe my first real job
is
this is a real job right like i'm
getting paid for this
good to know
now there was also a brand new poster
put out which shows peter and strange
with the city above their heads and what
is likely the mirror dimension shout out
to aaron s bailey on twitter for finding
the stock image that this was pulled
from and you can never not have a good
time with a sony poster however they did
release a better one that has peter mj
doc the lizard electro and salmon on it
you can also catch the green goblin 2
with his updated design that contains
his hoodie and also the goggles now the
final tv spot shows a better shot of mj
reading the new york post and on the
front of this we can catch peter
puppeting both her and ned if you cast
your mind back to the first trailer
you'll remember that she talked about
how the article said that peter might
have the power to hypnotize females and
the tagline at the bottom of the page
talks about these hypnosis and seduction
techniques i'm guessing that mj happy
ned and potentially flash are the only
people outside of peter's family that
stuck by him after the reveal and this
is why it's saying he hypnotized his
friends as everyone else is against him
mysterio must have done a great job of
ruining his reputation and this kind of
adds way more way to why he'd go to
strange for help also it's interesting
that it's the new york post that's
trashing his name as in the comics it's
of course the daily bugle but as we know
from the end of far from home that's
more of an infowars-esque show this tv
spot also contains a couple more frames
of the goblin's glider and we can see
that it's carrying the purple colouring
that it had in the raimi films in the
comics the goblin's costume is green and
purple but as raymie didn't bring its
design across he carried the colouring
through another way such as the suit
being green or as the glider was purple
anyway that's all the new details we
noticed in the brand new tv spots but if
we missed any then make sure you comment
below and let me know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy on the 3th of november and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the tv spots we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
some else to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of hawkeye
episode one and two which will be linked
on screen right now we pointed out all
the easter eggs we could find the
callbacks to the comics and just gave
our general reaction to the show so
definitely go check it out right after
this if not then thanks for sitting
through the video i've been paul you've
been the best and i'll see you in the
next one take care peace